crisis alimentaria en puerto príncipe a
esto es lo que se enfrenta a la capital
de haití debido al incremento de la
violencia
esta violencia ha tenido un impacto en
los mercados en el comercio en los
medios de vida y aislado en la ciudad
del resto de haití las carreteras hacia
el sur se cortaron hace un año las
carreteras hacia el este se han cortado
hacia la república dominicana y las
carreteras hacia el norte
más de 50 personas han muerto en
enfrentamientos entre bandas desde el
viernes dijo un alcalde local en el
marco de un aumento de este tipo de
violencia en la nación caribeña grandes
zonas de puerto príncipe están
controladas por bandas los datos que
tenemos muestran que la situación en los
últimos 90 días ha empeorado y que
estamos en un punto de partida en el que
haití es un lugar muy vulnerable en el
que ya había un millón de personas en
esta ciudad con inseguridad alimentaria
aguda
las entregas de suministros de las
cosechas como los plátanos no pueden
llegar por carretera porque los camiones
corren el riesgo de ser tiroteados o
retenidos por él el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu dijo que sus
entregas se han visto atrapadas en el
fuego cruzado por lo que ha creado un
servicio de transbordador vía marítima
que lleva la ayuda alimentaria importada
a puerto príncipe y a otras partes del
país también está utilizando vuelos
cortos para sus trabajadores sumado a
esto la inflación de los alimentos se
sitúa en torno al 52 por ciento la
crítica situación pone contra las
cuerdas en la frágil economía de uno de
los países más pobres de américa latina'